grenada is a paradise in peril
the ocean and the tropical weather that
sustain it weaponized by climate change
touching every aspect of life here
telescope bay is on the east of the
island
a community being forced out by the
encroaching sea
makeshift defenses not enough to hold it
back
there is no more choice i have to find
somewhere else
to put this house
patricia richards has been here for
three decades but it's time to leave i
feel angry
because i know it's it's humans that
cause climate change
we human we did all the wrong things
because right now the sea is up on us
and it keep on coming
and there is no stuff in it
and it's not just at sea level
more intense rains are destabilizing the
soil sending homes and businesses
tumbling down the hillsides
all of this will need to be rebuilt
elsewhere they move a road away from a
river that constantly floods
part of a huge effort to protect people
from the effects of climate change that
are already here
on this island alone that's going to
cost hundreds of millions of dollars
that's way more than it can afford and
it's a story that's playing out on
climate vulnerable nations across the
world
that's where simon steele comes in he is
grenada's climate minister and an
increasingly powerful voice amongst a
coalition of dozens of island nations
demanding a massive influx of cash to
help them adapt
survival is such a base term
i want more for my children than
just to survive i want more for my
people i want more for myself than just
to survive
we need to be able to to thrive
the cop 26 climate summit in glasgow is
now just days away for many a last
chance to secure what is needed
i think it's make or break
entire nations will be under water
what price what price do you put
in the lives of people
what price do you put
on
our culture
our right to exist
it is a warning and a plea to the world
one that the people of this island hope
is heeded as they cope with change they
did not cause do you worry about the
future
yeah
the amount of fish we used to catch
you don't see this among the fish
anymore
it's difficult for us as farmers now to
cope we cannot really plan because we
don't know when is a rainy season when
it's dry season simply because climate
has changed during this past year we've
lost two crafts
back to back that can affect you
financially it can affect you
emotionally mentally physically
as world leaders prepare to make
decisions that will shape the future of
our planet
grenada is a symbol
of a looming david and goliath-style
battle for funding
one that vulnerable nations are
increasingly determined to win